uh they had this is done originally on a
college campus so they had male and
female
um Confederates as they were Republicans
doesn't meet people from the South but
it's just members of the experimental
team
um who were judged to be moderately
attractive walk up to members of the
opposite sex on a college campus and say
hi I've been noticing around campus
lately I find you very attractive would
you and ask them one of three questions
would you go on a date with me
uh would you come back to my apartment
with me
would you have sex with me and they
simply recorded the percentage of
individuals who agreed to these three
different requests and of the women
approached about 50 percent agreed to go
out on a date with the guy six percent
agreed to go back to his apartment and
zero percent agreed to have sex of
course women typically need a little
more information about the guy of of the
man approached by the female Confederate
also about 50 percent agreed to go on a
date with her 69 percent agreed to go
back to her apartment and 75 we'd have
secular
how did it how you're a man how do you
answer yes I'll just go back and have
sex with you let's just start there
let's start there it's a great question
and well first of all
um
uh one qualifier is that
um these Confederates were judged to be
moderately attractive but and equally
equally so
um for men
um
sexual opportunities are very rare now
it may not seem that way in the modern
environment with Tinder and college
campus hookups and everything but
historically
um sexual opportunities were very rare
and even in the modern environment so
you go on
um Tinder for example
and uh or OkCupid is another dating site
and there's studies on a just a rate how
attractive members the opposite sex are
and Men rating women it shows this
normal
distribution where some women are very
attractive some of them are not so
attractive you know as a large number
and kind of in the middle or different
range you ask women how attractive men
are
only about 20 percent make it up above
threshold
um and most women find most men just to
be below threshold on attractiveness and
so what that means is that men find
women on average more attractive than
women to find men
uh and so um and so these guys who are
approached by a woman this has probably
never happened to them in their life I
mean of course it happens to uh movie
stars right because it's a very small
amount of men that are actually getting
the action yeah in the ranking of it all
because there's so many so much criteria
and so much judgment on a woman wants to
mate with that or have sex with him or
connect with him so there's just the
pool is Tiny of the men that are
actually having sex with women right
right exactly and and it's gotten
tinier in the sense that um
uh the men who are having sex let's say
the top 20 percent are having a lot of
it
a larger number of women
um and then in essence monopolizing I
was leaving a larger and larger share of
men who are sexless and and that's why
you have these phenomena the inso is an
extreme example
um but there's this pool of men who just
um uh can't find women
who uh are attracted to them and and
this is where this gets back to our
earlier discussion of the mating crisis
where
um these guys are spending all their
time on uh on watching pornography on
social media uh playing video games uh
and so they're not interacting in real
life and how do you develop mating
skills you know skills of Attraction
skills of social interaction so you
actually have to meet people and
interact in real life and these guys are
not doing that and so there's has been a
rise of um anxiety and I think it's
actually anxiety of several different
sorts one is simply social anxiety where
men feel awkward and when they
especially when they meet an attractive
woman they don't know what to say what
to talk about or they you know and they
get kind of paralyzed with anxiety
uh and so they tend people tend to avoid
things that they're anxious about so
it's kind of this vicious cycle
um and then fear second one is like a
subset is meant fear rejection yeah and
which is um you know when they approach
a woman if they and they fear being shot
down
um for a good reason because they often
are shot down
um uh but the um the fear of rejection
has this paradoxical
ity where even though we're supposed to
live in a sexually egalitarian World
ninety percent of women still expect the
guy to make the first move right another
catch so they're expecting the guy to
make the first move he's paralyzed with
anxiety and doesn't want to risk being
shot down uh and so they tend to avoid
interacting with women and so don't
develop the kinds of mating skills that
they need is monogamy
completely natural I get asked this
question a lot of your humans
fundamentally monogamous or are we
fundamentally religious or promiscuous
or polyamorous right is marriage and
mating just to do with now like Beth in
the old days with uh keeping uh family
land in the land and the family or you
know riches or things like that or you
know the way I think about it is that we
have humans have an evolved menu of
mating strategies we don't just have one
long-term mating peer bonding and
catchment and I think that is part of
our mating strategy so if you go to our
closest primate relative who's the
chimpanzee with whom we share more than
98 of our DNA they don't have anything
resembling the long-term rating strategy
or a pure bonded mating strategy they
have the female comes into estrus female
chimp males mate with that female when
she's an asterisk she doesn't conceal it
she either you get the bright red
genital swellings and the over fat
Factory cues and then after she the
estrus phase the males are indifferent
and they don't interact much with the
females anymore and they don't um and
they don't do anything for The Offspring
either so but in humans you have these
three things that have co-evolved so you
have one is the evolution of long-term
pair bonds right and it's one of the
mating strategies I'm I missed this menu
two you have relatively concealed
ovulation so compared to our chimps you
men can't tell when women are ovulating
or not and a lot of women can't tell now
some women are very sensitive to their
bodies in the modern environment you you
can
get that information but three you have
the evolution of very high male parental
investment so in contrast to the male
chimps men do invest heavily in
Australia not always of course we have
deadbeat dads and guys who abandon their
families and all that but but compared
to all other primate species human males
men do invest uh sometimes a couple of
decades or more in their children they
protect them they feed them they
provision them they they put a shelter
over their heads Etc and so um so so so
we definitely have
long-term peer-bonded mating now that
doesn't necessarily mean monogamous
mating because we also have short-term
mating
we have a fair mating infidelity uh as I
as I mentioned uh we have serial mating
which is very common in our species so
you made with one person for a while
break up and then mate with another
person for a while break up and so worth
it
um that's a very common pattern
especially in the modern environment
um and then we have people who mix and
match and then a small minority of
people do polyamory
um and then historically there's also
been polygyny which is one man multiple
wives and that is
um against the law in this in in this
country but we have sometimes what you
might call effective polygyny you know
which is that top 20 of the men
sometimes engage in you know not
necessarily simultaneous wives but maybe
one long-term Aid after another after
another after so an extreme example
might be a Leonardo DiCaprio you know
who uh I'm sure you've seen those charts
where as he gets older the age of his
girlfriends stays the same
yeah lucky him
I mean George Clooney I think sort of
did that for a while before he settled
down to what seems like a very happy
long-term uh marriage right
what triggers that
what triggers settling down
to a happy long-term marriage
um I don't know that's a great question
um I know one guy and I don't know if
this is a general answer but his view is
he he's gonna mate
um as much as he can with different
women until his mate value kind of
plateaus and then he's going to start a
lock in a high maintenance best you can
find woman so I I mean I don't I don't
know I mean I still have a I mean
another example of that in the Hollywood
arena is Warren baby you know who is a
notorious
um ladies man in his day but then met uh
Annette Benning and and settled down to
uh like a 25 year 30-year relationship
with four kids and so forth so probably
good not to count on a guy in his 20s um
settling him down if he's in the top 20
percent oh that is the catch right there
if he's in the top 20 percent be careful
of that because they have more options
and like Chris Rock said you're only as
loyal as your options an exaggeration
but there's some truth to it as well
that
men who who can who have the opportunity
so and that's why you get um I mean
that's why it becomes problematic for
you know and I know I mean you've your
involvement in in racing and the Sports
World and you're familiar with all that
the the star
athletes
um and sports figures and rock stars I
mean they got they got a huge amount of
attention
um from women you know I mean oh yeah
the women definitely make it obvious for
the men I can't say that from the other
perspective being a female athlete the
men don't make it as obvious to women I
mean they can but I think it's much more
it's a much more dangerous situation for
a woman wanting one of those top 20 men
who especially are Elite level
performers and celebrities to to imagine
that that's going to go well if you want
right and and the you know and the
problem is that it doesn't stop so even
after
uh let's say um
Leonardo DiCaprio let's say he settles
down and gets married
you know does that mean that they're no
longer going to be any women interested
in him well I think the women will
continue to be interested in him
um so uh so and that that that you know
offers a set of temptations that you
know men are tempted to act on some do
and and but as we talked about earlier
some don't you know some don't want to
jeopardize their relationship and choose
is not to act on those things if you
like this clip and you want to hear the
whole episode click at the bottom of
your screen